pas payer des postes c'est ça je vais
poser des questions à chaque chroniqueur
sur une image d'actualité télé vous
allez jouer avec nous bien entendu celle
ci le chroniqueur répond bien il reste à
l'antenne
si le chroniqueur répond mal il sort de
l'antenne d'accord le dernier qui reste
désigne le chroniqueur qui ne sera pas
plus
et voilà lors de sa d'ordre de son
retour d'accord at elle dit castanet
allez on y va on y va
question question pour sophie cost café
josette dans tous en cuisine avec cyril
lignac
elle a perdu son dentier elle a taclé un
plat de cyril lignac
elle a montré sa culotte où elle a
oublié le nom de cyril lignac
qu'est ce qu'elle a fait son office vous
jouez avec nous j'osais tard j'ai pas
regardé travers les vitres et de lignac
bah on va dire qu'elle l'a taclé sur
lignac à la tacler cyril lignac et bien
on vérifie tout de suite en images c'est
pas bon je salue josette saisi vos
josette
j'appelais c'est normal on est confiné
cyrillois là on a le sien aux toiles
acquerra poli il et il est chaud le
servir donc voilà je vous le dis donc
c'est normal
voilà donc et elle a oublié le dos de
quelqu'un serait arrivé d'arrivée devant
une star voilà et qu'elle oublie votre
prénom ou bien qu'on vous prenne pour
quelqu'un d'autre c'est à dire qu'on
arrive on fait un match doit revoir à
mes mais c'est pas possible c'est
michael douglas est ce que ça vous est
déjà arrivé
mathieu oui mais alors je te promets que
ça m'est arrivé il ya quinze jours dans
la rue quelqu'un du verbe en disant oh
thomas de la rue je vous adore
non thomas de la rue d'alleray à la voie
là elle avait rien elle avait rien du
tout dans mes et toi est-ce que tu as tu
déjà trompé sur un nom sur un truc
annonce avec quelqu'un de connu
ah si une fois c'est musicographe
discuter avec quelqu'un à côté et
j'étais persuadé que c'était une
personne du personnel je suis demandé
s'il pouvait m'amener un coca est même
venu à vélo j'ai tout ça et ils
parlaient pas français jettent à ces
hyper bizarre ils ont mis des gens du
personnel pas français j'imagine pour
les stars et en fait c'était james blunt
moi il m'arrive à moi il a il m'arrivait
un truc je vais vous raconter ses effets
de rigolade je sais pas si vous
connaissez il ya deux joueurs de tennis
il y en a un qui s'appelle nicolas
escudé et un autre qui s'appelle julien
benetteau l'acd gauche et des grands
joueurs de tennis français et j'étais
donc à côté de roland garros et je
croise un mec et je lui parle et je
croise nicolas escudé et donc et dans ma
tête pour moi c'était julien bénéteau et
je lui dis pendant je lui parle pendant
10 minutes
je lui dis ouais non mais tu sais que
ton match hier mais j'ai regardé tout on
mate
mais tu vois mais c'est exceptionnel ce
que tu arrives à faire à la volée ce
revers chopé mais comment tu vas
travailler vraiment vraiment me c'est
exceptionnel julien et là je vois que le
mec il est un peu relou bas c'est normal
et pauvres du royaume ce qui me veut lui
il parle de quoi
ben ils prennent pas de ça et s'en va et
je vous jure que c'est vrai j'étais avec
mon pote loïc qui travaillent avec moi
vous savez mon bras droit loïc est
toujours après il n'y a pas du tout de
suite
deux jours après il me dit tu sais
c'était pas un ni collègues il suffit
pas c'est pas julien benetteau insisté
nicolas escudé a annoncé qu'il
essaierait ou alors
deux jours après le conte bâches
installées des comptes à terme ou
quelqu'un d'autre toi alors qu'ici
tabernaux m'appeler c'est qu'elle dit et
dit bonjour de ceux ci qu'elle dit non
mais moi c'est mon psy castaldi oui tout
à fait musical dick et ça a duré je
pense qu'il l'a fait exprès pour
m'énerver
il va plessis qu'elle lit pendant un an
c'est qu'elle dit jamais fait l'effort
castaldi grand patron de m6 qui est
vraiment pas mal à hambourg de mecs que
j'adore voilà que ça ne te crois pas
qu'on perde ans maintenant ouais non non
non non je n'ai pas un physique pour sa
mère et pour ta mère me compare à ma
grand mère ah ouais je comprends
maintenant parlons de grand mère on à
gilles verdez gêne pas pour jean michel
maire mais très très souvent ah oui
enfin versatile et la bcp plainte adore
assez fréquemment et récemment il ya
quelques semaines j'étais au théâtre et
j'ai croisé gtx pas tout j'ai croisé
nathalie marquay ma vie salle où
jean-michel nombre associe tout le monde
a déjà pris pour qui toi ouais un jour
chisholm faire il ya des trois quatre
ans les officiels de la fiction de la
rochelle
je sors je suis joueur et je sors et là
il ya les pics numérique mais je vous ai
tort dans cette série plus belle la vie
sur france 3 alors évidemment c'est la
photo mais je lui ai dit que j'étais pas
la personne et l'hôtel pensais tout
simplement les chéris vous me ferait
penser la prochaine fois quand je fais
le tour ne jamais finir par maxime
gainey sophie calle c'est bon tu
élimines et ma chérie tu fera plus
partie de ceux qui ne seront pas payés
question pour benjamin castaldi
qu'est ce qu'on a pu voir benjamin dans
la carte au trésor un oiseau faire ses
besoins sur un candidat
la règle du jeu la plus compliquée au
monde un caméraman se casser la gueule
ou 1 m m un vent de force 12 à un
candidat l'a4 un mec met un vent de
force tout un candidat un mec mettre un
vent de force 12 un candidat castaldi
qui regardaient t il est confiné hisse
au second benji regard des réponses sur
ce bo1 il y a trois noix de coco tu vas
devoir le porter comme terrines et
suivre le parcours que voici
il va falloir passer au dessus du
premier obstacle puis sous le deuxième
obstacle est au milieu du troisième ce
qui n'est pas évident du tout avec dix
kilos sur les épaules lorsque tu
découvres une couleur sinois qu'une
chose à faire c'est sauter sur le bas si
tu as ton ici et rejoindre la bonne vous
et c'est à dire la jaune la rouge ou la
bleue pourquoi parce que ce soir ce
n'est pas le coffre aux trésors que tu
vas devoir ouvrir mais ce qu'on appelle
un aspect c'est un panier de pêche en
osier qui est au fond de la mer et puis
tout est clair pourquoi tu peux vous
dire est qu un calepin pour noter la
balle ça va donner à l'épreuve à
l'époque je vous jure que c'est vrai
vous êtes chez vous vous êtes ou debout
dotée de la boîte alors qu'est ce qu'il
a dit est donc un appui s'éclaircir et
le ferroutage j'adore franchement ça
doit être une galère à animer cette
émission de tana le point que moi tu me
donnes trois règles mais moi jamais je
pourrais faire ce que fait cyril mois la
règle jugée libre et coûte moins bien
voilà tu vas dans le coran le granth là
bas voilà et c'est le premier cas pris
le truc terminée
c'est un vrai professionnel pas comme
moi franchement cyril féraud c'est un
vrai professionnel mois de l'attribution
elle aurait été réglé en deux minutes à
la carte au trésor bon bien ça aurait
été très vite sa part allé la carte aux
trésors qui a fait 2,1 millions de
téléspectateurs hier castaldi
malheureusement vous êtes éliminé aussi
bas vous partez vous ferez peut être
partie de ceux qui ne sont pas payés je
vous le dis pour l'instant il n'y a pas
eu une bonne réponse à deux questions de
mauvaises réponses
on va passer charlot à celui qui est
quand même spécialiste des médias
oui regardez il est là il est beau
bien entendu il est devant sa caméra et
oui il est bien le special event chantal
ladesou à udine il ya douze mois à venir
et y dénombre déjà massés que c'est pas
maxime c'est bien pire
gilles verdez merci chéri non non c'est
maxi argile dénoncé maxi maxi dans top
chef
quel truc un peu relou diego un candidat
qui s'appelle diego at-il fait et on en
profite pour embrasser digue il a
planqué des amis il a fait un tu l'as vu
à hélène darroze il a dégueulasse et
l'assiette de ses adversaires ou il a
appelé sa mère car il ne se souvenait
plus de la recette
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait défaut je crois
que c'est la réponse est que les élus
médoc il a planqué des aliments ont un
spécialiste médias c'est pas pour
enfiler les perles et ma voix là bim
maxi on regarde la réponse
[Musique]
alors l'idée de mon message c'est de
faire vraiment un rond très nette
[Musique]
bien sûr nous sommes éclatés
je sais que l'oeil du chef vous peut se
concentrer sur cette tâche-là légaux
[ __ ] dgo [ __ ] mais je suis désolé où
j'étais sur mon dressage un peu en folie
et une petite piqûre il a deux galas
dégueulasse et l'assiette de ses
adversaires pour l'instant trois
questions trois mauvaises réponses des
génies dans cette équipe la question tu
sors pour l'instant ait eu d'égal merci
mon maxime il ne reste plus que trois
candidats pour ce jeu le pas payer du
post je vous jure
et je vous le dis aux téléspectateurs
s'il n'y en a pas un qui donne une bonne
réponse d'ici la fin c'est je prendrai
la décision vous lit personne ne sera
payée lors de la première session de
rentrée
ah ben ça c'est sûr attendez on peut pas
bah ça c'est sûr voilà je vous le dis
c'est sûr et certain
mais tous ces gens qui bossent pas là
mais c'est incroyable allez justement
matthieu delormeau c'est pour matthieu
delormeau
on va parler du jt de 13h de tf1 il
quelle surprise
quelle surprise a reçu jean pierre
pernaut pour son anniversaire en direct
très bon anniversaire en janvier -
messages de tous ses correspondants une
chanson de la part de mireille mathieu
que j'aime fort et kddi qui nous
regardaient tous les jours pendant le
confinement mireille donc si elle nous
regarde juste un gros bisou et je
l'adorent un gâteau de cyril lignac
ou alors une insulte de la part de
gilles verdez qu'elles ont prises en
refusant pierre pernaut pour son
anniversaire en direct mathieu de long
alors sans aucun doute c'est là à la
première
pourquoi pas parce que je connais j'ai
regardé que ce travail non parce que je
sens que vous avez le regard à droite là
vous avez regardé quelque chose on est
très fier c'est pourquoi je peux vous
montrer parce que je regarde le retour
ici c'est vous
l'âge et la télé qu'à ça ces pages
découpées le salon mais dans un chalet
pour ja oui mais vous regarder à gauche
pas du tout reculé aujourd'hui avec 24
enfin écoute
comment vécu à gauche en bas de mon
mieux et qui a imprimé d'abord les
personnes sous la table et tu crois que
j'aurais en 3 secondes
j'aurai le temps de taper des trucs oui
de leur montée accepte un petit peu le
fait que de temps en temps j'ai bon
voilà aybar 7,6 d'être sûr d'avoir bon
mathieu delormeau
ben oui quand sa bosse en bosse est ce
que vous êtes sûr et certain oui je vous
dis mathieu dorment aussi ça n'est pas
la bonne réponse c'est vous me faites
l'année prochaine vous faites un don
gratuit
je vous laisse une dernière chance de
vous rattraper
non mais ça marche pas comme ça cyril
les petites règles à la tunisienne on va
arrêter maintenant tu as posé la
question je réponds je te dis ah c'est
bon c'est pas bon on voit la réponse la
culture bienvenus
vous êtes sûr il vous est donc à auxerre
donc ça fasse autant chioui aujourd'hui
avec sébastien aubert qui est notre
correspondant dans le nord vous le savez
bien comment occupe-t-il son confinement
eh bien on va le voir chez lui à
villeneuve d'ascq nous raconte ce qu'il
fait avec la complicité de thierry
chartier sébastien bonjour jean pierre
je n'ai pas du tout envie de te parler
de mon confinement mais plutôt d'un
événement qui nous tient terriblement à
coeur à nous tous les correspondants de
tf1 dans les régions c'est évident avant
ton anniversaire c'est aujourd'hui bien
sûr alors on aurait aimé réunir la
chorale des correspondants pour chanter
une petite chanson c'est pas possible
donc chacun y est allé avec son
téléphone portable a fait une petite
vidéo
et voilà ce que ça donne ici à bordeaux
à montpellier sur les de toulouse pour
un accord à marseille à la réunion à
nice à lyon à strasbourg ajaccio à
clermont ferrand à metz et dans les
hortillonnages d'amiens
on ne souhaite un très joyeux
anniversaire jean-pierre encore une fois
bon anniversaire je te promets l'année
prochaine on sera tous réunis autour de
toi pour fêter ça dignement
en attendant de loin on embrasse tous
très fort à tous merci à tous les
correspondants font un boulot formidable
je m'attendais à sebastian où racontant
son confinement avec des jeux des
flandres et autres et ben non merci
infiniment et bravo pour le boulot que
vous souhaite joyeux anniversaire
jean-pierre voilà très bon anniversaire
mon jean pierre pernaut est ce que et
bravo très bonne réponse de matthieu
delormeau qui reste et qui sera
certainement pas le pas payé voilà du
jour les cherry est ce que jean pierre
pernaut pour vous c'est le meilleur du
jt pro-cnt est ce que vous le mettez au
dessus d'un an sophie lapix de laurent
delahousse de gilles bouleau
si vous deviez me fait râler un top 3
des présentateurs de jt le les trois
meilleurs et celui que vous trouvez un
petit peu le moins bon allez les trois
meilleurs éléments vous allez gilles
premier pernaut indiscutablement c'est
celui qui colle aux français c'est le
meilleur deuxième je pense que je
mettrais gilles bouleau d'accord et 3e
je vous dis très franchement j'ai du mal
je n'aime pas de la hausse mais il faut
reconnaître qu'il a le mérite de tenir
là où si tu veux tu peux ressortir des
labos m pujadas bas bien sûr temps
il encore la coiffe la bien nommée sur
lci comme un objet pernaut deuxième
pujadas et un troisième
voilà boulot je pense que la carmma que
mathieu est alors je te dire pujadas
lapix boulot mais surtout père dont je
n'ai pas en numéro 1 pour moi pernaut
pardon de dire c'est pas un animateur de
jt il anima magazine à 13h30 dans lequel
il met ce qu'il veut c'est un magazine
mais les régions et tout ça mais c'est
pas un animateur de jt qu au sens où
l'entend la porte plus il apporte
méfaits magazines de time magazine deux
temps voilà il fait un magazine sur tf1
il fait pas un jt est d'ailleurs
vraiment aller pour moi ils apportent
ils apportent beaucoup plus que tous les
autres après bon voila vous faites ce
que vous voulez gilles je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec mathieu je trouve que
c'est une vision très bobo très
parisienne bourgeoise de dire que
pernaut ne fait pas agité il fait le jt
de la vie quotidienne des français sur
ces deux meilleurs brigitte et c'est le
seul que tous les gens regardent
regardez vous en parlait récemment il
suit quasiment ses prédictions ses
indications
c'est celui qui sent le plus la france
donc c'est un présentateur de jt bien
sûr trois mois je vais pernaut ensuite
en deuxième plage mais boulot égalité
avec pujadas en troisième je vais bruce
toussaint
j'adore excellent qui est un conte un
peu décalé un peu différent et
tranquille et il est très original aussi
savent excellent excellent bruce
toussaint je suis assez d'accord avec
vous les chéris question maintenant pour
géraldine maillet wi fi vidéo tourne
énormément ce moment oui je vous la
montrer
géraldine de la shoah série mais dans un
instant on saura si vous allez être
payés ou pas tout de suite été votée on
joue ensemble
oh pas payer du post on voit tout ce qui
s'est passé va la télé sur les réseaux
etc mais géraldine maillet je veux vous
poser vos questions il ya un instant je
vous rappelle que celui qui sera le
dernier à rester donc il aura donné que
des bonnes réponses pourra choisir celui
qui n'est pas payé aujourd'hui on a déjà
perdu le castaldi sophie koch maxime
gainey qui son parti allait faire un
moelleux au chocolat les chéris wazi et
la question où est ce qu'on a vu un
ch'ti devenir une star du net malgré lui
sur bfm lille dans les marseillais dont
le jt de 13 heures ou dans gym direct
géraldine maillet j'ai eu mes règles
chez google gym direct - suivi direct
sur ces 8 est évident damman dans l'est
évidemment
ah oui surtout capa chim direct en ce
moment c'est sûr et certain regard des
de confinement je travaille je fais pas
de sport je prenne mon chien je prends
une nouvelle de ma famille mes proches
les personnes seules celles qui sont
dans le besoin et à 20h j'applaudis les
soignants dévoués qui risquent leur vie
pour la nôtre
je suis plusieurs dans mon bureau au
travail est effectué les exercices que
les enseignants dans vos partenaires et
c'est parti pour 30 minutes de sport
petite balade avec mon chien avec bien
sûr l'attestation de déplacement
interrogatoire imprimés et rend fou et
merci à ceux qui nous soit dit nous
protège ce qui peut mettre notre pays de
tenir de bol il est génial est lui à lui
je l'adorent franchement il est
exceptionnel les chés question pour jean
bardet merci géraldine maillet vous êtes
merci question gilles verdez si vous ne
répondez pas c'est matthieu delormeau
qui gagne
que s'est-il passé pendant un live
instagram du chanteur raphaël
il ya une coupure de courant il s'est
pris un coup de pression par sa meuf qui
faisait à manger ou à bouffer voilà
comme ils disent
son chat a fait pipi sur le canapé ou
amel bent a débarqué pour le prendre
dans son équipe
alors je suis formel c'est l'abbé donc
il sait pas un coup de pression par sa
veuve
absolument ça c'est une très grosse
rigolade regarde
et si jamais jamais
non pas de nous pas de jours
[Musique]
l'armée sur la chaîne direct c'est un
truc facebook arrête de l'intérêt commun
[Musique]
n'est pas pour longtemps
c'est basique
qu'est-ce que ça c'est mou de ce
confinement et pour tout le monde et à
nous ils en appellent franchement s est
une star de ouf c'est un artiste non il
prend des coups de pression comme vous
et moi
il est tranquille il prend une tannée
par samassa sortir la poubelle et arrête
tes conneries sur facebook avec la
guitare
non mais c'est ça qui est magique pro
sport high et comme julie
fatou qu'il convient pas elle c'est
l'artiste on voit le ch voulons genre
d'audience
ça me va lui arriver de lire des poèmes
à côté de lui lalala lalala y est tu l'a
bouffé parce que la cdc leurs doctes
arrête tes conneries c'est pas l'heure
me faire décoller le conte sur un
facebook live où les conneries comme ça
ça c'est magique s'approche alors
mathieu tu es toujours là
elle est où cette écoute à l'essai il a
rien compris pays voulait que je dirais
que j'ai rallié son truc qui m'a marqué
c'est pas grave mon chéri question vous
êtes les deux finalistes attention dès
dimanche ou tank est sous haute tension
park est un chauffard s'est il fait
poursuivre au jour un policier sosie de
stéphane bern ou et vous mais que
signifie cette mascarade
voilà merci un motard déguisé en père
noël un jeune en trottinette ou et
isabelle morini-bosc on déambule at her
alors je vais dire à la subtile emmerdés
là je vais te dire là la saison la
trottinette merapi n'ai pas vu ça ouais
hein je n'entretenais d'ankatso de
tension marqué un chauffard s'est il
fait poursuivre regardez cette rigolade
en fait j'arrive à côté de la rue de
rivoli et donc un feu rouge et joie une
voiture qui passe au feu rouge et qui
percute donc un piéton ce piéton et
projetées en l'air par la violence du
choc et retombe lourdement sur la tête
la voiture ne ralentit même pas et
commencent à s'enfuir mais crise ne
l'entend pas de cette oreille entre le
chauffard et le père noël justicier
s'engage alors une incroyable course
poursuite dans les rues de la capitale
loin de se calmer la femme au volant de
la voiture noire n'hésite pas à remonter
la file de véhicules en sens inverse
malgré les risques évidents de cette
poursuite en plein paris crise ne lâche
pas la fuyarde devant l'église de la
madeleine
le courage de crise va payer ils
repèrent deux motards de la police qui
vont croire au témoignage de cet
improbable père noël
[Musique]
immédiatement les deux policiers se
lancent à sa poursuite
quelques dizaines de mètres plus loin la
voiture folle est enfin bloqué par le
trafic
les policiers ne prennent aucun risque
il braque la jeune conductrice et
l'obligent à sortir de sa voiture elle
est folle cette image franchement je le
redis dire dans quelle fut haute tension
incroyable franchement c'est ouf ça
alors les chéris question pour gilles
verdez qui peut peut-être gagner le jeu
toujours dans quelques tensions quel
mytho un homme positif au test
d'alcoolémie a sorti aux policiers j'ai
bu que deux verres j'ai confondu l'evian
et la vodka c'est parce que j'ai
embrassé ma femme qui était bourré ou si
votre collègue qui a soufflé avant moi
gibert d alors je vais répondre parce
que je trouve que c'est beau la ses
lacets c'est parce que j'ai embrassé ma
femme qui était bourré
réponse regarde et je roulais g mois
calculées le bus c'est vous qui était
venu taper dedans way l'attitude de
l'homme met la puce à l'oreille aux
gendarmes
manifestement il ne semble pas dans son
état normal
est-ce que vous avez consommé de
l'alcool obtient un petit peu ok c'est
bon
[Musique]
vous avez vu combien de deux heures de
20 d'accord parce que là du coup vous
êtes positifs reçus ouais c'est embêtant
j'ai bien un paiement j'ai bu deux
verres de vin à table et un irish qu'on
fait à la fin il va pas
un repas
à partir de 0,40 la personne en taux
délictuel non je suis pas un peu on va
voir la machine ne le dira aussi
impossible
[Musique]
je conflent
0,56 et médicaux en gros ça veut dire un
grain de 12,6 fait beaucoup il est
génial huilé excepté limite aux aux
flics c'est exceptionnel à aller pour
vous départager les chéris gill et
mathieu puisque vous avez tous les deux
mal répondu ouais ça va être sur cette
question dans le journal de m6 on a vu
un mec remplacer un masque de protection
par autre chose mais quoi
un tapis de voiture une feuilles de
lasagne une chaussure ou un slip
c'est pour moi celle là non c'est pour
les deux fois les limites
celui qui l'a dit ah non je dis là des
lacets la date et la lâcheté tous les
deux brad est tous les deux deux génies
de génie est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
m'a donné une bonne réponse regardez les
ils avaient des masques
tout le monde n'en a pas alors certains
se rabattent sur d'autres types de
protection cela va du chapeau
d'anniversaire à l'eponge en passant par
les serviettes hygiéniques ou les
chaussettes
pas sûr que cela fonctionne alors
d'autres optent pour des combinaisons
intégrales dans les supermarchés sur les
réseaux sociaux on voit de tout même un
client en tenue de plongée
on n'a donc toujours pas de gagnant les
chéris voilà donc ça se passe bien pour
les de l'attention de leurs mots et
gilles question au corps et on a eu
droit à un grand pascal praud pourquoi
il a ramené et but 3 litres de camomille
il s'est mis à chanter du maître gims il
a gueulé sur son portable qui n'arrêtait
pas de vibrer où il a eu tout faux
pendant une interview du maître gims ai
marre j'ai dit lâche et là c'est donc il
a gueulé sur son portable et vous il
s'est mis à chanter du maître rythme
effréné le cas la bonne réponse vous
regarde vous avez écrit un très joli
texte
un très joli et textes qui s'appelle je
suis un terroriste pacifique
j'ai changé le titre virus à ça
s'appelle virus bois alors josé j'ai pas
vu la mauvaise herbe
version je suis donc virus et c'est
vraiment un texte qui sera publié dans
la règle du jeu qui est un texte qu un
texte un peu intello et ben voilà les
mecs toujours pas de bonnes réponses
très concrètes dont j'ai mis un s que
l'espionnage déjà qui a eu tout faux sur
un invité un jour moi ça m'arrive à
chaque fois un bon à chaque fois les
invités jeudi un truc c'est arrivé je
vais t'aimer sur europe 1 je recevais un
arrêt de temps et il a compris tout de
suite j'ai pas vu le film ce qui vous
arrive jamais vous seul but des kings
l'invité est en fête ou deux et en fait
ils accomplissent elle rien vu et il m'a
pourri pendant une heure et gestion se
sentent seuls c'est horrible vous avez
un talent c'est de faire croire ça vous
dérange pas moi j'avais la route de ma
vie où dit la vérité
c'est par eux je peux faire le buzz je
peux vous comprendre alors si vous
voulez partager sur 7 sur 7 il s'agit
par là une vidéo tourne énormément ce
moment c'est un mec qui a fait quelque
chose dans un centre commercial
mais quoi il offre une fleur à chacune
des caissières
ils payent les courses des manies il a
pété dans le micro du magasin où ils
vendaient les rouleaux de papier
toilette à l'entrée du magasin gilet
matelassé à glace et là c'est moi la
salle à manger une différencier je vais
dire là des noms c'est la cs qui régnait
ce qu'il ya une bonne réponse
regarde
c'est bien sûr le fils benjamin castaldi
alors mathieu qui n'est pas payé
aujourd'hui il va zy fais toi plaisir
alors j'étais un plaisir je peux pas
taper sur l'équipe parce que ça fait
cinq ans que je les connais je les aime
socgen visiter la nouvelle
donc ça va être sophie je t'embrasse et
merci pour le pognon eh ben voilà
sophie et ben voila ma chérie tu n'es
pas payé aujourd'hui mais on aime quand
même
sophie en tout cas un tueur sur des
réseaux il ya des il ya des réactions
sur les réseaux il ya mieux il ya des
gens qui disent des génisses et
journalistes médias voilà merci à vous